geopolitical analyst Olli Bruckner
joining us here on the program today
great to see you today sir thanks for
coming on the program with us it's clear
the CSU have won the larger share but
why does it look like a defeat well it
has been a historical moment for the
Conservative Party in Bavaria because
they managed carefully in the last 50
years to understand what people want in
in a part of Germany that always
pretended to be a little different than
the rest of Germany and they lost the
ability to understand what people want
in Bavaria and that is why they lost the
majority which sometimes made them feel
as if the stability of the party is the
same as the ability of democracy which
is totally wrong and in a way a lesson
in modesty what is he is perhaps as you
as you allude to the CSU is now out of
touch with a voting populous but it is
the CSU's worst result in over 60 years
my can you bring us a bit more details
why did it go so badly wrong for them
well it has a number of reasons as it
was already mentioned the style in
politics and the communication within
the coalition gave a terrible impression
of the state of the conservative party
if you have a sister like the Sears who
you don't need enemies and people got
the impression that instead of governing
it was much more about a personal fight
and the personal crusade of the Minister
of the Interior the former governor of
Bavaria see Hoover and he appeared to be
the biggest problem and strategically it
meant that if he believes that mark
removed the Conservative Party too much
to the right to the center too much to
the center then there is room on the
right for parties like the I of T and he
decided to imitate the positions of the
I of T which apparently didn't pay off
the other problem is that if you don't
understand what the importance topics
are for the people in your democracy
which are much more green topics like
revenue
and climate change consumer protection
questions and instead you play with the
fears of people that migration could
cause problems within the country and
you also misunderstand what is actually
going on in the country crime rates went
down the country is doing better than
ever and it's not like the end of
Germany as we know it just because we
lived up to the commitment of a
humanitarian position when we helped
people in need since 2015 so what does
this mean though for the future of
Angela Merkel it is she sitting pretty
with lots of time left in her position
well in two weeks time we have another
important election in the financial
center of Germany which is hessin and
Frankfurt where all the major banks are
located and this is a different scenario
because the governor of Hessen supports
America and it also doesn't look very
bright for him so we generally speaking
in a face that is the end of the year
America and if she will stay in power
until the end of her term it's a
thousand days if it comes to an end
quickly which is also a possibility then
we will see a major shift within the
German political system but this is pure
speculation we simply don't know what's
coming up next
geopolitical analyst of Julie Bruckner
joining us Erin RT International thank
you for your time and thank you for your
insight
you